Many applications require configuration
settings in secret such as TLS certs
to run in a production environment.
One problem we saw before when we used
Docker was that many devs want to
bake in their configs and
put those on the public Docker.
Don't do it.
So then what should we do?
Some say to put configuration
management tools into the Pod.
You can, you shouldn't.
There's a better way.
In there are Configmaps and
Secrets to take care of these problems.
Configmaps and
Secrets are similar except Configmaps
don't have to be sensitive data.
They can use environment variables and
they can tell downstream pods that
configuration is changed along a pod or
restart itself if necessary.
Let's talk about secrets.
It's really easy to create
a secret from a file.
Using the cube CTO
creates secret command.
In our example we've done this and
the Kubernetes Master already
knows about our secret.
Then we can upload that secret to a pod.
Let's see how this works.
What happens if we start up
a pod that uses a secret?
Well after we run this cube CTO
create Pod command, a pod is created,
then our secret is mounted
onto our pod as a volume.
This way creators can make sure
that our configs are there
before our container start.
Once that volume is there,
we can take the contents of it and
expose it on the file system to
wherever our pods would go to mount it.
Then our pod starts to come online.
And finally our container is spun up.
We're good to go.
So now let's have Kelsey
teach us more about
creating Secrets to store
sensitive application data.
And creating Configmaps to
store application config data.